and welcome guys who punched drunks for
today beware winners win and we are live
we are now running on black time on the
shell which is the norm yeah speaking of
black time nany not here yet
yeah nanny's never here on time she gets
pregnant pumps out a baby at all the
sudden she's on stripper he's not I hate
it was when people use babies excuses
for my kids make it to the show my baby
would have his baby I had three jobs
yeah I know right you know why he's born
cuz I was late for work had to get to
work joining us in studio she's a young
Christian warrior she's gonna talk about
what's like to be an Asian woman in
America that's the cool you should have
a website dedicated body part that you
have because there's some dude who just
wants to make weird love to Asian women
body pie like you guys are like I love
Asian chicks oh boy I don't even have to
show my tits or but yeah like I'll be
like who wants to see my elbow yeah
ten dollars see my pinky toe speaking of
weird speaking died on the game of
thrones this weekend he's here to talk
about what's like to get eat buy a
[ __ ] Walking Dead Chris heist
everybody a wizard the wizard the dirty
wizard the comments are very funny comic
I've seen is this your only outfit you
have yeah pretty much describe him as a
minimalist yeah what is your how would
you describe yourself I describe it as
Unabomber anybody else sure you know
anti-authoritarian comic yeah geez up
Jesus broke Jesus Jesus his pissed-off
brother yeah he's my brother
okay right the LaToya Jackson a [ __ ]
Jesus
yeah yeah he's my brother I'll [ __ ]
care nope you're late stay the [ __ ]
outside Christine
on the show and she comes with her oh my
baby dies okay okay well good news for
you we just started guys a lot of big
shit's going on people are talking [ __ ]
popping - Annie yeah what is it
Oh what is on time how long does it take
to brush one tooth [ __ ] okay three okay
well then I guess it's three times as
late every tooth is starting to cost us
money though
yeah November 1st 2nd I'll be at the
Grove in Lowell Arkansas oh yeah were
you playing [ __ ] Cheesecake Factory
grove comedy club The Grove comedy club
yeah doesn't seem like there's more and
more comedy clubs opening up every day
you know people just rent out rent out
places it could be a little hole in the
wall and then you call it a comedy club
you get a sign and we need more that
like strip like it's probably in a strip
mall never been anything that isn't an
established comedy club I like playing
and if it's a female or owner I'd like
to play it even more I think they're
just I just enjoy them as owners not
that I'm very tight with a lot of male
owners but the female owners just seem a
little bit more so when is your gig
November 1st and 2nd November 1st and
2nd you should do some one-nighters
together let's do it let's figure it out
let's put a pack of assassins together
you know either brush yeah that's good
Jason
hey guys Jason keeping consistent with
his pedophile [ __ ] it you should put out
whole clothing line for pedophiles be
like dude if you did all kids this is
the action where you need identikit oh
well do yours because my mine are insane
I don't really yours are important I
don't even know what I have oh really
usually have 90 minutes of gigs going
into the 20 to 50 I know I don't I don't
remember that gigs on Mars you plot
all Saturday I'm doing Alice mania what
about tonight
is it sold out in Vegas who knows when
Johnny will put this out but we're live
right now oh [ __ ] we are live tonight at
the calm before only for eight years is
comedy chaos live first show Christina P
Co Vaughn Tony rock Jeffrey Ross more
people I can't remember the other ones
myself second show Joe Rogan ah Joe
Rogan Chris D'Elia
Eddie Bravo um preacher ma a preacher
Lawson and Steven is easy and Jeff
jessimae Peluso all live those tickets
range from 20 to 25 dollars just go if
you use the pro on the first show I
think you use the promo show chaos and
you'll get five dollars off so get that
get those tickets cuz I believe both
these shows will I am this weekend this
Friday night I am doing the North
Hollywood comedy fest of all my friend
Jack junior at the gap from I just
studied I going back there I love it
I've been there in years and I xpod cast
comedy club confessions he just started
it oh that's cool
that was a great one arm may 2nd through
the fifth I'm there this Friday night oh
and then sorry then this then I told you
just get it going baby Cinco DeMayo I'm
into come in the mayor of the Comi store
doing laugh lounge Cinco DeMayo show I
will be in brown face you kept going I
was like oh I wasted my nanny's plugs
all right since we're live I might turn
up Tuesday's tonight it's a black room
tonight
turn up Tuesday's home it's on Ventura
Boulevard and wheel free to get there
late it's a black show yeah my favorite
part black shows is that the host does
about 30 minutes in between these Tom
and under like the commercial break yeah
I'll be right back on stage after this
they tagged every bit that you had yeah
and then you go back next week now it's
their pit and when I say day I mean
black people cuz we're racist and I deal
kids once again I did all kids da great
add some dates real quick in nine months
I'll be giving birth because I'm
pregnant
ah I'll be doing an open mic in an
escape room December 25th at 11 a.m.
get your tickets now protesting people
protesting a protest this weekend hey
people it's our right to protest and
then tonight I'm testing my theory that
my mouth cures aids
wish me luck spoiler alert it doesn't
I'm a seventh I'm a flappers comedy club
and how many kicks you got [ __ ] it's
cuz I don't have a baby you know don't
hold me now and I show up places that
brush you teeth all morning welcome to
the number one train podcast we run
trains on our female guests we see if we
can hello hello did you go to college
University of Illinois really did you
where'd you grow up
Chicago I did not know that about you oh
damn damn did you guys ever see each
other walking by each other I walk by a
couple ages before it I'm sure you saw
somebody that dentals kids who were
driving around with van what color van
did you have I'm mostly just jump out of
the bushes like oh okay there were some
guys in our neighborhood we're like
pulling down their pants in front of
kids really yeah might have been you
yeah that's you know do you mean yeah I
do know what you mean
I almost got molested twice oh that's so
cool and I do joke about it open for
Bobby Lee yeah so uh haha I almost got
molested by Larry watts and father Dan
and I honestly don't believe I believe
it didn't happen cuz I'm I swear I'm a
grower not a shower and I think banana
dick kids get more [ __ ] trouble than
like your
they're like this kid don't even get
hard for it it's almost mush then they
took off your pants said no no because
there was this whole thing where we are
they called it a bloodbath father Dan
would do bloodbath where he go to coffee
with kids you know where you used to
shop call it a baptism Chris grab a
chair stop creepy never know I was just
gonna say if you look at this it looks
awesome are you talking to with him just
menacing exact girls and I would say it
oh that's so great if we never talked
about yeah I was just saying man you go
hey speaking of Rocco owners today we'd
like to welcome guys we've got a new
sponsor and I've never been more excited
I love all of our sponsors but this one
has a special touch baby no no but
that's but it'll make a girl be proud to
announce that blue 2 is now a sponsor of
punch-drunk Oh guys you like good sex
who doesn't remember the days when you
are always ready to go do you remember
those days ah no i don't i call them
thursdays i mean like I've never had
problem with boners but I just like to
take boner pills I just love I don't
know you love and why you're so hyper
always your Energy's like okay man I get
the blue chip one day I'm not talking
enough to your mound of walking it's the
yelling okay I'm alone you want me to be
I love it the yin-yang - welcome -
monotone Sam and we're talking blue now
you can crease your performance and get
the extra confidence in bed listen up
blue - calm that's blue the color blue
blue - brings the first chewable with
same fda-approved active ingredients as
Viagra and Cialis
so you know they work now here's the
thing - yeah if you guys know they say
if you take a boner pill
the next day you get bad cramps and your
legs I don't know what I think it's
trying to be that true I think it's
trying to make your legs rock-hard like
I think it thinks your leg is your dick
and you're like dude it's the worst with
blue - that doesn't happen how do I know
because I tried to OD on these things
they sent us a few samples and I'm not
gonna lie I'm getting a little low and
these things work like a [ __ ]
I'm not gonna say I'm not mentioning
names myself only I'm awfully alone yeah
I swear to god it works like a an ass
and deliver them right to your house you
don't have to go and girls take them
like our nipples would get rock-hard or
what I think I think you get angry cliff
or maybe your nipples get it [ __ ]
just rock hard there's only one way to
find out we should do something where we
do a YouTube video like you do a boner
pill and he takes plan B and see how it
works out when I tried to hang out I
really noticed something extra now this
isn't just for guys who can't perform
it's for any guy who wants extra
function to enhance their performance in
the bedroom got it you want to [ __ ]
[ __ ] and then start [ __ ] right again
yeah whoa chill dude it's so funny man
when Chris when Chris Hardwick got in
trouble with his girlfriend she's like
he made me had sex what I didn't want to
yeah I go that's called the relationship
right dude dude I've had three
girlfriends when I woke up they were
[ __ ] riding me I was sleeping and I
just wake up to there oh sure right dude
cuz I rock sleep boners you know I'm
saying so it's like dude boom you could
go now right now we got a special deal
for our listeners visit blue to calm get
your first shipment for free with our
special promotion punch-drunk one word
just pay $5 ship okay you know you get
your first one and then after that five
dollars for a bunch of boner pills
you're boning me are you reading it
again who wouldn't pay five dollars to
come like a crazy person
well I mean it sweetheart against five
save a lot of $5 do what yeah you know
like guys are known for keeping coke
around because like they may not joke
but girls like girl shop like chicks
love I don't know whether that boner
pill we show up with nostrils ready to
inhale yeah right
I wonder if girls ever just keep boner
pills around just okay what's going on
here pop a couple iiiii could easily see
that our guys allowed to buy plan B can
i buy Plan B and be like hey watch it
okay looks like we're gonna get a plan
we need a blue to sponsor well you're
gonna be transgender and your transition
oh yeah don't judge me
ya know here might be knocked up anytime
okay
again that's blue blue2 CH aw calm promo
code punch-drunk you don't need a
prescription you don't have to go to
doctor there's no embarrassment there's
no nothing going on just ships right to
your house why would you embarrass your
boner people are different they're
normal people yeah are we right yo e
most guys keep a lot of coke around okay
some trash heap shows up yeah people
don't actually I'll do that Sam
to you that's a common move we're very
proud of I am very proud and I'm very
happy to have them on board and I think
our audience is really gonna love that I
can speak for them I've used it I loved
it I'm gonna continue to use it oh and
if anybody wants to help me use it I did
all kids guys ah cool what's new man
you've been out how long you been out in
LA now I know you moved on you know the
avians are airing this Saturday Oh
Showtime wow that's a turn-and-burn
right there 11:00 p.m. Eastern Standard
Time on Showtime and you host it haven't
seen it yeah but they like you know we
shot stuff like on the convention floor
and the greatest me getting dildos
thrown at me whatever by the way you
avatar is so [ __ ] great okay so
either you've watched a lot of gangbang
porn or somebody goes let's try this
picture did you ever watch porn are you
ever an informed person what's the kind
of porn do women watch dick-sucking I'm
shy know that you like [ __ ]
interracial girls on girls I like that
better than guys in it yeah do you know
Simon watching bestiality because I'm
Lea these are old girl Esther ku you
watch dog porn yeah we've seen girls
like sucking horse [ __ ] okay and I just
think we're getting to that well look
who smiled the [ __ ] creeper back
there and that's been punch-drunk
everybody just lost our sponsors oh no
go on go on with that you're so
beautiful you have to suck horse [ __ ]
for living here's the thing dude I've
seen those videos once I audition for
the horse okay I can't believe how high
the production values gotten on these
[ __ ] like they used to be like like
weird eight millimeter ladies having a
lavalier mic on the horse
yeah the horse of the [ __ ] the dogs
got an age in he doesn't want [ __ ]
red M&M there's a [ __ ] script doctor
there's a [ __ ] I said no kibble your eye
you know so funny if you talked about
that in stage people would just shut
down it's so interesting how nobody
wants anybody to talk about real crazy
[ __ ] on stage right well I think there's
a and when you have couples then like
everybody's judging like oh did my wife
laugh at that my husband you know it's
like does my wife or like on like date
yeah and then they get in fights why we
say if you want to find out the girls to
keep her bring her to a show with like
either David town or stick ideas put a
horse sticking around whatever it is man
put it on there and if she laughs at
she's a keeper if she doesn't laugh
[ __ ] run cuz there's no need to date
somebody
who doesn't get comedy right no totally
I back in the day and I'm cool them now
I'm happy he's doing well but oh my god
my favorite comics Dane Cook I would
literally run for the door say Chris
D'Elia no no I love Chris I do I do you
love the girls that listen to Chris
D'Elia I do I mean I like smart
audiences who care listen those are not
the audience members you want listen I
do do I want smoking hot tens look at
the following they're loud and who cares
they come they bleach their [ __ ]
right you by themselves right
I would love dude I know I used to
listen you could either you get to a
point where you could either love
somebody or player hate on them and I
like Krista Lea so Marcus Tullius I
loved watch him go outside and just
abandoned themselves these girls come to
nightclubs come to the comedy store
dressed like they're in a [ __ ]
nightclub gear and they just saw that he
decides back when he wasn't date he's
got a girlfriend now but decides who is
the who gets the Royal penis yeah I
loved it and then these girls like have
the gall to complain like I had sex with
a Collette Krista Billy and he never
called me back it's like was in [ __ ]
right these chicks don't realize when
they get to hang out with royalty your
job get in get the [ __ ] out the Kings
got to go to bed okay like that's a like
if let's say some stupid like [ __ ]
bimbo chick was just hanging out here
right let's say for example fight nanny
fight nanny was here before and uh let's
say Chris Rock comes in right the guys
of the room automatically know the
hierarchy of of who's who right but
bimbo chicks like hey Chris Rock and
then they think C's she's on it because
she looks good in a [ __ ] period she
has a million followers on Instagram
those are the worst one I love you fam
your fans beating off your pictures I
know what family you're from but your
[ __ ] fans are slow strong he wants a
million family members
I don't talk to the four that I have
laughs Oh would it be because they're
buried six feet under like you're doing
like one of those classic your mom's
like look at my girl girl right that'd
be so uncommon imom and Instagram a long
time ago so I followed your mom my mom
has a paranoia of like the biggest
conspiracy theorist like she just thinks
like everybody's wiretapping her oh
that's where you get it from dude dude
let me tell you this one time my gran my
grandmother remarried like late in life
like she got remarried like in her 60s
and her husband was like one of those I
pray all dudes just like bored like
crazy all dude and he would just say the
craziest old people [ __ ] and he goes hey
don't go to McDonald's they're selling
you can't go room meet ya cuz kangaroos
are so cheap to ship kangaroos meet to
America instead of all the cows we have
here there really get no these are like
squirrels in Australia I love that
kangaroo me is like worse than cow me
too like it's got ink it's me how about
that one but yeah but how expensive
would it be for McDonald's I know I
learn hamburgers I know we're good like
the horse got like lost still me I said
this before and I'll say this again I'm
glad you're dead bud Jesus Christ what
happened is that a lot of haunted talk
to her she says I talked to you laughs
oh cool what were some of the was the
best joke ever
on on the Showtime AVM Ward was by Doug
Stanhope and I say it all the time it
was it was so smart and so funny goes
the AVN Awards are the only awards where
you could get newcomer and Lifetime
Achievement Award in the same
a wonderful job my favorite job dunks
and hope is a national treasure
oh he's a yogi hosted they would be
cutting to like porn stars shaking their
tits on camera like it's more organized
now but back when he did it was like the
wild wild west it was like they had just
started but that's everything everything
was great and then the bean counters
come in and you know it's like look at
the UFC the UFC is no different than
comedy right remember back in the day
you got Sam Kinison doing blow
you're about redfox it's like supposed
to be shooting a show and he's half an
hour late because he's doing blow off
some audience members [ __ ]
another like dude I'm a vegan I'm
straight edge I don't drink I'm trying
to cut out air if I could cut out air I
could not breathe that would I take
other people's air did 17 years ago
Jarvis and I Oh Stan Opel took us on the
road to San Bernardino let me get there
Friday and there's nobody at the place
and he was giving us each a hundred
bucks and there's nobody at the place
and they go do this show Saturday so me
and Stan OC end up had the date wrong so
we're still there and he's like I'm on
the road tomorrow but he goes but
there's nobody it's it's like big-ass
country bar there's nobody there that's
just a staff hey view anyway no he goes
we're still gonna do the show and he
goes I'll double both of your money and
he goes to Jarvis you in your underwear
at the end of each a punchline I have to
do a cartwheel and I'll double your
money and he goes you to me you have to
do your whole set completely naked so we
just do it so me and stand up for a
dying laughing a Jarvis who tell a dumb
joke and do a [ __ ] a half-assed
cartwheel then I go up completely naked
and it's like four people than the staff
and Stanhope and Jarvis I just do your
act totally Nick and he gave us 200
bucks because we were there there's
nobody there that drove off in the
corner
ah Jarvis was not sent home but that's
how much I love that guy like we showed
up at the long day and he's like ah
we're still gonna do this you're gonna
earn your money but I'll double it but
you have to entertain me dude
he made me do the same thing 400 that
bar would I would have as well that bar
suddenly packs why is everybody out here
there's an Asian but [ __ ] naked I
heard there's goes out like to probably
2002 maybe
is that crazy 2008 is back in the day no
that was like 2000 to 2008 is but that's
back heard that's 11 years ago that was
like prehistoric times it's hot time
flies when you're high yeah joints
outside that was a cigarette like I got
a new fetish asian chicks smoking
cigarettes so I have this [ __ ] fetish
of clogging toilets I like to no no I
mean I'm at I have this phobia tell me
you heard that really I love to murder
people I mean I am afraid of Murray
afraid of murder I gotta finish I'm so
pro rapist coke dealer number I'm too
old to do coke man I'm talking about
I'm too old dump into old coke is in the
young man's game it's a young man but
anyways I know plenty of people older
than you who OD done coke for it yeah
that's a goddamn boy you guys you know
everybody will have to come to darkest
half these guys don't get stage time
anywhere else is the only time they get
to get up by the way I know this was a
bad day for Asian comedy do you see yo
she just tanked it at Brody's [ __ ]
muammar oh my anybody know dude kids how
Michael Yoshi we gonna ask him how he
felt about two people dying that night
hello so anyways I super fear of
clogging toilets I don't even know if
it's a naked someone look this is it
based in reality do you enjoy this
everywhere you go I've clocked toilets
for sure I feel like that's normal
what's the girth of yeah I think
everybody no one wants to call you
anyone's toilet I hate using the public
bathrooms and but I used to go to like
Asia like China Japan and I would I was
like [ __ ] Mike I took Godzilla shits my
[ __ ] like Jim
we take Godzilla shits to come but you
guys eat like rice yeah well that's how
we stay skinny utilize for sure but I
would crush their twist and they don't
have any like plungers anywhere so I'm
in China the poop waters rising I see a
[ __ ] button that says emergency so I
just hit it right there's a ring at the
door look bang there's a ring there's a
dude with a plunger right there bhau's
comes in plunges the [ __ ] out that's the
hand of God that's the chaucer bow he
goes alright I think this is the end of
the series of punch talk cuz that's the
greatest story I've ever heard
immediately like he's staying outside oh
yeah don't find it oh I go to work you
know my dad Wow is that true that's the
guys I said you're just sitting there I
like it's the guy sitting there like oh
cool that's the god-honest truth and
then what happens he bout to hear me
bounce to you and then you go back to
[ __ ] her he was done [ __ ] yeah
yeah done [ __ ] what do I hold it I
don't know plug it again it's like now
you push it pay something the last four
minutes of the story anything's enough
anything is possible so I used to do
these Chinese gigs and then one time
they put me in a hand to God a haunted
massage parlor it was haunted as [ __ ]
it's known for being a haunt you know I
could hear [ __ ] it was so funny because
I was like those are trafficked what
those were the women who were trafficked
for sure and I was like is anybody you
hear screams and I realized they were
Chinese ghosts who don't speak English
so I'm like is anybody here like god I
got got a [ __ ] and we're like no waiting
for a ghost translator dude I was like I
don't know before google translate
that's stop pounding on it no I want to
I mean you can hear okay how do you know
it was it was it known for being haunted
actually you turned him off I'm fine
pirate I was it known for being haunted
or you know creepy [ __ ] cuz you know
there's some place that we're like hey
come to this funny these people are so
racist when I went to China they thought
I was Chinese really yeah well they are
completely racist be very racist because
there's nobody there going hey dude
that's not right it's literally one of
the most racist people I know yeah but
he gets away with it yeah because you
know everybody feels bad yeah yeah yeah
he will he needs to blow up hilarious
he'll be super fun he'll be fine he's a
great guy and he's hilarious by the way
Steve Randolph saw next week and we're
gonna talk to him about all this awesome
character work he's doing he has a thing
shop by the way has a Mandarin podcast
like didn't ya hear all things coming
nobody cares
1.5 billion people care what a smart
it's not [ __ ] six chinks oh that's you
all right yeah
how goes called Mandarin jury Chinese
people are chander dream tapping that
Chinese [ __ ] hell yeah bro are they
gonna do a Chinese special with him
hell I don't know I've had to go to war
for Esther ku oh thank you so much I
appreciate that to me because they get
mad at you and I find it very
interesting because
you know I would tell you the most
racist comics against Asian people are
Asian comics and it's not you it's like
most of your Asian comics do like jokes
are like look look my mom speaks
[ __ ] and [ __ ] like that and the
fruit the fact that they like okay come
on me it makes no sense yeah to me
they're all awful you know they're all
just told to hate on me so people just
don't want anything for themself what do
you think that I don't know you really
don't know I mean you must have thought
something going on in the Asian
community
we're they're really trying to cash in
on this oppression [ __ ] totally I mean
it's like it's like stop it black people
are way more oppressing we are like what
do we get oh you know you might get
mistaken for being on the honor roll you
can't drive we all know that if you want
you don't want you want that go away
learn to drive better okay right
you eat everyone I always tell ages when
you're turning like look to your left
and right you can't rely on your
peripheral well it's just like for
people like be a part even like they
drive so slopes like we're really ughter
we apply for a handicap sticker just
because my small eyes that's so funny a
video series just you trying to be
recognized as handicapped but Asians
have that ah the highest rate of
standard of living they have they go
there more doctor and scientist there's
the mean in the world are in America in
America okay yeah it's like then than
Jews and blah blah blah but higher than
Jews yeah you hear that Ari they're the
highest if more they have more doctors
than anybody else I mean like they have
more two-parent homes to to parents more
than any other group out there and it's
like you're not oppressed and literally
this girl goes to me oh well you know oh
you don't know it's like to be fetishize
they go what yeah they fetishize oh oh
ho you get hate on everywhere you go
oh god options people want to have sex
with you that's your oppression right
like we have like the highest rate of
online
dating like everybody wants to bang us
sorry white girl yo you're old news
she's old she uh knocked up but it's
like it's so interesting cuz get into
this whole [ __ ] a oppression thing
they want cash in on it and it's just
like there's nothing for you to cash in
on know it's like so minuscule the
complaints like they're complaining
about me that's how minuscule they are
or how about that chick who went after
what's-his-face in the late show that
has a Late Late Show bear Colbert when
she went after him because she didn't
get the joke right cuz she's a [ __ ] I
don't remember that one
and then she did then she started trying
to do stand-up and she was 20 at the
time and she's talking about beat racism
and B I'm like you're 20 tell me about
the racism of 1998 and what you had to
go through when you got [ __ ] born
into this world all the oppressed the
only people who oppress Asian people are
their parents you got following around
and exactly like spanking us the thing
is when Asian parents spank you they
include shame in it and like my parents
I could stay like made us get naked like
your stanhope gig you're standing there
in front of our siblings with no pants
on getting hit like you never get hit
with none spank with nunchucks no but
belt no no black belt black from what I
can tell they also karate girls laughing
covering their faces like you're gonna
say that's why our faces are so flat no
no no no no my buddy had a great bit
about Asians make bad boxers because
their faces are like catcher's mitts but
that's a different joke oh but no these
asian guys they complain that like I'm
outspoken about like I because I talk
openly about Asians cuz we're not all
crazy rotations again you're also Asian
yeah so I'm allowed to talk about
because I have a cider it's your life
experience China they killed millions of
girls and then one eighth overall good
job China like speak out against like
hey that our communities [ __ ] up like
yeah we abused our children and all this
stuff and it's like oh well nobody spoke
up for those millions are you thinking
who got executed or like dying
orphanages that are really
great yes yeah yeah yeah it's like I
listen go white guys to just to the
worser [ __ ] they they killed one
asian chick that and that was the big
story I think that even you were that
was involved when they were going after
you and I don't know if you had
reference there but like one white guy
killed an asian chick and East Asian
chicks were talking yeah you got looped
into it cuz you joined the Twitter love
the salmon attack I get in I just
thought that's a Hulk smash
and I started smashing people and
they're delusional cuz oh yeah I [ __ ]
your mom one big Asian dick I'm like
okay so you obviously have an issue with
the size of your penis it's really
getting to you and you bring this [ __ ]
up I go dude white guys three Asians
like [ __ ] what do a jig ice do to Asian
chicks ah North Korea you see what he
did to me in the hallway you with his
dick pic of you with his dick it's like
when Sam stayed at that haunted brothel
in Korea yeah so enough asian talk I
feel like we're just doing that and I
think we need to move on yeah let's make
fun of [ __ ] peda wait you were
telling us before the show we never got
to it cuz we saved it you robbed Johnny
Damon at one point in time yes I was you
know that's the thing Asians make really
good robbers cuz no and this is our
baseball talk nobody ever thinks that
you know where else any anything like
naughty mischievous oh you're always up
to naughty yes we don't think you're up
to fellas but I look like every other
Asian I never get recognized right so so
yeah I thought Bobby Lee was on the show
for the party so uh so yeah I ended up
that Johnny Damon's house one night and
ran back randomly how do you randomly
come back well he wasn't there there was
a Pittsburgh pirate staying at his house
and my boss met him on a plane a night
camp no no no what I had a sales job and
she brought us like three girls to
Johnny Damon's house to like party
uh-huh and then she got fired because
she was like really she was like like
bragging at the sales meeting she's
saying oh yeah my girls like kept me up
all night at Johnny Damon's house it's
like shut up [ __ ] like the bosses are
here you know oh yeah like because they
were like well he could have had a gun
he could have killed you
who Johnny Damon could have killed us
yeah that's why I gotta happen
that's right cuz I think there's been
one pro athlete but this was back when
he was on the red sauce how many
baseball players roll athlete I was
about tonight goes all your to Rae
Carruth and OJ Simpson but what about
that dude Williams shot that dude with a
shotgun oh yeah how about white athletes
can we say why athletes little kids
- well have you ever dated famous guys
no never Oh her no okay quick and I love
her to death
she just dates d1 pro athletes all the
musicians as well
I don't like jocks all right they have
too much testosterone
what's your wheelhouse well I like I
like like skinny skateboarders really
you know how do you mean like give me a
wimp that I could like overpower Natasha
Leggero likes that she always dated like
nice like they're just emo is you mean
Ari Ari
Duncan and OSHA Moshe all I love all
them they're all wonderful people but
they all could easily be picked up our a
little guy you are you dating your
wrestling what do you do you mean like
were you overpower I don't want some
like huge muscular guy like overpowering
me why don't you date Brad Williams
before he's married did you guys see
that video that little black [ __ ]
beating up that chick I just want curb
stomp that [ __ ] [ __ ]
what was that is that wait it's on
Twitter I want to fight the guy what was
that video that you sent me that I
didn't watch but it was all is that
something we could talk about it we
can't talk about no there's a video that
we made was based on one of my jokes
about how I like today ah Mexican chicks
that don't speak English
cuz I think it'd be hot video there any
later you remember we made that video I
don't remember it you don't remember the
video where you and the porn star you
bang the maid and Jose Trey Hills like
translating to her everything you're
saying oh I do remember that yeah
like we made a video about banging a mic
about 40 of them which one are we
talking about here
so I did a joke about you know having
translated into bed with a mexican chick
they can't speak English and yeah and
it's really funny and like so I have a
separate I do I do something called
twerking and politics
well I rip twerking videos and then I do
like the news I got this it's this whole
thing I do so I started this channel
called twerking politics and I wanted to
take off all my dirty videos off my
normal YouTube channel and put on this
video channel and so one of them is
called love conquers all and like all
the rest of videos have two thousand
three thousand this has a hundred and
thirty thousand views I'm like what wait
that's the video that had all in Arabic
yeah that's why I thought was so funny I
go did you press translate oh I didn't
do that so easy to translate nowadays oh
my oh yeah okay we got to do that right
now okay here we go
maybe that's what the terrible yesterday
was about your video will post this very
beautiful putty nothing i've ever
translated a mer isn't there a button no
I think that sign means my computer has
more buttons than you are okay you got
the super Sam Sam's computer doesn't
have an F yeah but dude look at this
look at this but what me I got I got
Indonesia acaba ha ha ha every I mean
it's ah ha ha ha this is they all start
with the same thing though like the same
first sentence there was like oh yeah in
a row dude
it's something something maja faqad
something is that dude this literally is
like when South Park tries to do like
[ __ ] melesa acaba acaba yeah that's
every tres - Ana yawn yawn yawn pakka
Hana yawn Hana McCain munch on bar video
I love it they don't have a word for
video in their things so they just use
the word well funny thing is like you're
on the you are you
shooting that show by the way how'd that
go shooting in your TV show dude it was
so much fun here at upstate New York or
somewhere no we were in the we were in
Montauk New York okay good and we were
studying the Montauk Project and it's
out gonna be out in July and I got
feedback that they really like me so
hopefully we'll be able to use me in
future ones
nice nice nice amazing yeah so you got
your hat yeah I actually like I didn't
get and and I got a shirt I said that I
normally wouldn't buy touristy sure plus
said is that what the shirt said I
normally wouldn't buy a t-shirt but I
bought this but all I got was this lousy
t-shirt sex drugs and lobster rolls and
that's everything that I love you know
and say that are you that I can honestly
admit those are Sam's three favorite
things yeah bro boner pills in there
thank those lobster food trucks No oh
yeah I'm a little suspect to that
there's this place alright but my
sister's in Culver City her address is
five to seven one whippoorwill Boulevard
apartment for murder her
but right by right behind my sister's
place called lobster and beer you've
been there it's like a little dive bar
you kind of place but yeah every day
have lobster tater tots lobster tacos
they have lobster everything it's so
good their lobster mac and cheese no bar
there enough for that place well copy
running out of lobsters well eventually
probably we're running out of everything
well dude you know how like the building
next door to the comedy store got bought
out that that's a sushi place turn
market onna yeah we've got bought out is
that really yeah my favorite sushi la so
you know they're gonna do they're gonna
knock it down turn to a [ __ ] other oh
way that's the best sushi in LA yeah and
my friends at GM I get like a mad hookup
I hope they I hope they I hope they die
in them when they were involved dude can
you talk to somebody in China tell them
to stop buying everything on Sunset
place all Chinese the place across the
street their stories all Chinese they
have no souls well you know they like
they want to buy the Comedy Store that I
think they made an offer just well dude
I mean like I think it's gonna cost you
so much money to buy that
building but they should never give a
price because they'll come up with the
money
absolutely they'll have them on somebody
well be like 300 500 you're crazy long
die
w so saddest don't send its World War 2
around guy who sneaky around I go talk
to them I mean like supposedly like the
viper rooms gonna be knocked down see
but like that's what's cool about sunset
is I can Hollywood is like all these
mom-and-pop historic places if they I
think becomes a scientific cups the
Vegas Strip who gives a [ __ ] gonna be
the baby it's a [ __ ] it's gonna be
literally condos use for Airbnb so
that's stupid he's it's so lazy dump it
dude drive by these buildings nothing
but their errands definitely clogging a
toilet right now right we know we need
that guy ancient Chinese secret to come
in and what kind of music do you like I
like a lot I like like 80s like erasure
is one of my favorite what's your favor
[ __ ] - music me he always happy to go
that happy birthday to you is my
favorite song - [ __ ] - it's just on loop
but once a year only once a year and I
use blue chew and I [ __ ] thanks blue -
did you really do love it well dude it's
summers coming we're in the spring and
guess what that means live music shows
and there's no better place to go than
our good friends at sea geek that is a
hundred percent true yeah I love going
to see live stuff you know what I think
I'm going to go to places Woodstock yeah
I'm thinking about doing that and then
Ralph Lawler the LA announcer la clipper
announcers getting inducted into the
Hall of Fame of in Naismith the Naismith
Hall of Fame allow Canton Ohio think I'm
gonna go to it and I'm gonna go buy my
tickets through see cake if you ever
need tickets for anything go to see key
check out our sponsor see key how about
some playoff tickets how about some
baseball tickets how about anything
Dodgers killing it rock clubs ah jo koy
concerts whatever it is you can go to
see key okay
I use them to go watch uh we went to the
LA Clippers game last week okay I just
got tickets from him to see The Avett
Brothers at the Greek Theatre in August
really
Madame is gone is like eight of us that
are going oh I got I didn't get that
call I been willing to bet you wouldn't
know a song of this dude how many bands
you listen to a lot Jesus very much a
lot of well if you're like t-bone you
listen to every band ever you need to
get on C key cuz your band will most
likely why I'm great sound dude SeatGeek
it's the best well C key it's at eating
company where the customers come first
yeah all tickets are guaranteed you're
never gonna get jammed you're never
gonna get screwed over and they will
literally tell you if it's a good ticket
or a bad ticket so uh seek equals in
millions of tickets in from all over the
web rates each deal on a scale to 1 to
10 and displays them on in the
interactive seat map so it's simple to
find what you're looking for giving it
green come on I can't cuz I got I gotta
get up and dance you know I gotta get on
that Jumbotron you're talking to get in
the aisle with my seeking to dance dance
you got text to read Chris I hate to do
it yeah Erin can we get another mic is
it possible Pikachu that's right so back
ball our listeners can get $10 off with
their first seeking purchase that's
right
I'll go to seat get download the app use
the promo code punch-drunk for $10 off
your first purchase you can use this use
that for concert tickets sports and
comedy Bert Kreischer maybe you want to
go see kill Tony I was just on there the
other day you want
I was just on there the other day there
were Dodger tickets were eight bucks you
use the code punch up that's a free
ticket yeah
eight bucks Bob you've got to be
kidding me now you've gotta be get we
just blew your mind
so that's seeking we appreciate their
friendship and joining us live a new
Tesla owner Brian Redman the coolest car
in the world follow you on Instagram
five words to show limit the coolest
part of the charges us $5 but we got
another Mike coming what what is this
okay
[Laughter]
that's quad pin I have a Tesla I got a
death squad pin last night you thing hey
Ben ah
when's that when's the shows gearing up
for the road I know some huge stuff's
going on with kill Tony talk to me
maverick talk to me in about two weeks I
think we start we go to Phoenix and then
Vegas and that's pretty much starts it
off for like three months two months
Venus and Phoenix that's you okay the
one in front of her mouth is the one
she's using we're all on blue - by the
way do we're blue - and like
[ __ ] boner pills I hear these
two agree decide who's bad shot I didn't
take mine I chopped mine up and I
snorted like a line with like a
Dustbuster with my dick is this like a
gas station one thing you want to really
get a blue chew shove it up your bot dog
right in there let it just and you know
how you get it up your butt with a boner
like you're loading a musket I don't
have an anus imagine she has a tear
between the two so it's just one big
vagina with [ __ ] in it so one lens Elmen
red banners me
classic red band line classic red
classic red bad
Oh red what's new how's the show last
night it was great we had a secret uh
yeah Nick Swardson but we'd also had a
secret Jim Gaffigan and a presidential
electors writing for president way so I
don't know if I'm allowed to say but
Tony knows him very well Clinton Oh
he grew up in Youngstown Ohio he might
have been with Elon Musk sexually why
are you talking in code you [ __ ] [ __ ]
Riddler because right when I started
saying I'm like am I allowed to talk
[Laughter]
congressman from Youngstown we don't
know politics people yeah that politics
guy do we look like we watch c-span here
yeah exactly because I mean dude that
does that sweater look like he gives a
[ __ ] do you think we are Jimmy Carr ha
ha ha Jimmy Carr ok are you done
don't look people who care about
American politics arrogance we don't
give a [ __ ] who's sassy over here I see
over an upstairs nanny without getting
into it you watch Game of Thrones no do
a spoiler Jason do a venture spoiler
[Applause]
what do you see in the event I can't
believe no I haven't let him you should
spoil it for him because he does that to
everyone Oh guess what happened last I'd
rather talk about the Colts picking up
free agent where I don't know about you
guys where mr. could be you have a team
at all is their team you gotta like our
baseball yeah yeah yeah no no State
Buckeyes oh that that would be if you
had to root for any sports team that's
what that would be what is that because
you and Tony are dating no it's because
when you go to Ohio that's all you know
and you don't give a [ __ ] about anyone
else yeah that's true it's very
interesting how the bear more popular
than the Browns and the Bengals look
good though dawg
and I'm taking that stage how funny if
that red band came on and got us back to
talking sports he sports fans yeah
walked in had some mail that said I have
a Tesla [ __ ] yeah and I gave me a pin
that completely shut the entire network
down and Ohio means good morning in
Japanese so you're already taught that
as a child oh oh that's what you have a
Japanese girlfriend no he bought her
[Music]
Woodstock has been cancer three days an
insider has told me got cancelled by the
way same that happened two days ago okay
well breaking news here no there was a
whoops we know
we know the ottawa's garnet no Johnny
hey I have come terrible news and I'll
start it off this way
by the way Garnett is first of all
slowly becoming um slowly becoming a
conspiracy theorist is he really oh yeah
I get texts all the time yeah I've heard
things about a moon landing that perhaps
happened or perhaps did not happen and I
apologize to anybody who has an opinion
either way you think that's a highlight
of his life you doing his oppression he
semi likes it but samurai hates it he
was very happy when Gabe was on because
I was doing gaming he's like now Gabe
knows how I feel yeah
nobody does an impression of me except
for Dan and O'Neill they only did it
like one time and their feedback was
like more Tripoli's well they do it like
every Marco means flat also Oh speak
about you should go on that podcast it's
the number one bestiality cop podcast
[Applause]
you literally brought it up no it's like
you're like I like watch it be no you
said what kind of porn do we watch yes
and she say oh but you're sick she just
out of nowhere goes I love to watch
girls suck course I can say that shows a
fast left turn
what kind of porn do you like I mean I
have frequented a horse [ __ ] sucking
pornos under the category of dick
sucking
yeah it's true you know you get bored
you watch your videos human dick sucking
you've seen them all yeah you just get
bored yeah you know how it is I get I
suffer from insomnia
he likes dolphin porn yeah I mean they
have great vaginas second-closest vagina
to a human vagina and the cleaner that's
great that's great I was wanted to stick
my dick in a blowhole but I was worried
it was like a cigar cutter I heard those
flotation tank centers have dolphins you
could [ __ ] no really yeah I mean like
in Pasadena right no need no robot
dolphins dude how is your odds studio
going they're still fixing the ceiling
they said it's gonna be done in two
weeks but we'll see at a in Pasadena
yeah I could still use I just have to
put it together and then use it and then
put it take it all apart which is what's
up yes I bring one of those tents you
got to bring your own roof right I'll do
this Friday at the Ice House Chronicles
oh dude what can I do it this Friday Sam
will be there this right I will be what
and then you'll cancel it I'm sorry bro
I'm stuck in San Diego I can't come I
have a wedding and it's like how did you
not know you had a wedding have you been
telling that it's his wedding in my
favor oh I forgot good married my
favorites he actually goes hey bro can I
go on this Friday show not sure like two
days later dude where are you dude I'm
not gonna make it by the way all right
guys check out his shows on Friday at
the dojo that was a great show nipple
all right four more views on YouTube
come on at the store later he goes I
just did a show where there was six
comics and two people in the audience
only because the host brought two of it
was it the host yeah yeah all right
that's been shrunk no I just hated I
tried to start a place go up I like I'm
waiting literally no help no no
you you did promote it I'm not talking
about you it's amazing how many people
complain about no spots and then when I
booked them here they do no promotion or
weed or uh USC viewing parties those are
always pack it's always a super fun time
so not a Sunday night Jimmy door did it
sold out though it's just like if you
promote it's full if you don't here's
the thing unless you're huge you need
about two weeks to promote there if you
don't promote two weeks early it's just
not packed and people get mad but it's
like hey dude I hate to tell you your
face is on the fire you didn't bring
anybody don't yell at me
yeah well hi look at it how you look at
it is that that place is awesome you do
and that's the first time out of like
five times I've done it whether it's
been like that so it's not in my opinion
it's normally awesome but but the thing
is it's not right if it's Friday night
and you're gonna go see a show it's just
hard to get people to go to hey you go
to this ball slide room bar I get down
but here's my whole thing is that one
it's free parking - it's cheap booze and
listen the Comedy Store can't put
everybody up she booze drugs by dog
dress review right now free parking I
mean it was a dicey thought I had to
Jimmy my way in - oh by the way if you
do look at the that was scary
today no good deed goes unpunished
well that sailor Danny I want to bring
the show to a screeching halt and throw
that on your tits or whatever yeah not
the shitty tits are you coming tonight
to help
I would know because I always go there
to hang out with you but if I'm not I
tell you we're all you know what about
that one time you couldn't find parking
and you just okay I had a breakdown one
time okay I told you guys I was having a
breakdown
I never you guys said I just don't show
up I'm up here rocking I've never not
shown up letting the home of not coming
sir sir sir sir Sir sir Sir sir Sir sir
Sir sir Sir sir Sir sir
so this is what the show's welcome to
the bad yelp review by the way I'm
coming for you not a bad podcast reading
Yelp reviews yeah why would you we
appreciate your community service Sam
thank you thank you
I mean dude there's three clubs here and
then putting up the same five guys yep
pretty much
and I tried no see
I was talking to somebody I can't marry
me hey there's like me and Jeff Richard
somebody I was talking to somebody he's
like you going to the store later and I
go probably I go who's on the lineup he
goes who do you think it's the same
[ __ ] lineup he's out of your lineup
tonight try to make that money honey
[Laughter]
yeah but that's what no you're right you
have to have this five people but then
there's a hundred other comics that are
great they can't get into that window
which is why I could sell 250 tickets
putting up all the young funny people I
would do it but it's like it's just
we've trained this town no six ah yeah
no one's arguing with you on this i 100%
you just kicking my dick Erin rewind it
all I said was I'm coming for your
children I'm coming for you got a cell
now or else would give the shows to
somebody else it's just the way it is so
and even that's getting [ __ ] weird so
it just is what it is dude I used to do
shows there all the time and you know I
started trying to believe in the younger
comics and not doing the same five every
week and then they're like you know no
we're giving it to Sam now too stressful
yeah it's always that terror the terror
attack it was like thwarted bomb yeah we
are lucky gonna bomb what they found
somebody who had like a plot to like
kill everybody no it was like an
ex-military person who sometimes yeah
well what in LA that's where it was yeah
I just read the headsman well it was LA
I didn't knows all that kind of it was
that long beach or something long I but
do you think I mean III what do you guys
think about this like everyone you get
out of the military you automatically
get tracked for like the next 10 years
you know like how about when you get out
of high school
no no military how about this how about
if the CIA the FBI know they're [ __ ]
up how about getting them before they do
something and not just sit in the car
eating doughnuts watching it go down how
about that one they want to collect more
evidence to make it worse one of these
guys we're on the radar they've met with
them the FBI's met with everybody's gone
nuts
the FBI they're so passive then they'll
like create a file yeah and then never
do anything went wrong then when
somebody doesn't shoot look we had this
file they were literally in the car
watching it happen the [ __ ] Shannon
tape murders the FBI were there in the
car cuz they were monitoring 200 though
whoever got killed by the crew sure to
you Sharon Tay they always know
they always have like a group of people
that they're watching and I'll never do
it that's why he's growing all that
facial hair to hide what cats or what
any new conspiracies that you're really
into he's gonna [ __ ] us all up what
fight G why do you believe that oh it's
basically like brain cancer
oh yeah kids are getting it they put in
by home elementary schools kids are
getting cancer what Wi-Fi you have the
5g so you think it's gonna be different
than 4G LTE and Wi-Fi yeah I mean like
the it's mean people been talking about
this forever and your RAC and people
getting [ __ ] cancer and headaches and
all that [ __ ] no way yeah I we were
driving we were drunk we were doing a
tinfoil hat tour through Arizona and say
was we driving through Phoenix we saw
multiple 5g towers being put up whoa
we're all gonna go back to like dial up
AOL days dude it's the safest mom
Springs his band 5g you can't yeah you
can't do 5g in Palm Springs Wow
how crazy is that like the we're
super-rich budget it was like that it
has to be passed by the FCC before you
know they're all owned by the [ __ ]
company they want us to die yeah it's
called extinction event did and if you
go to Georgia gall stones is that what's
called confirmed by wizard okay confirm
by wizard it says like the human
population should always be at five
hundred million people it shouldn't be
above that and we're at 7 billion so
something but it but if this is true
then then it's just gonna kill everybody
we're gonna be at zero that's what they
want they want to kill everybody know
keep a watch chunk gone a giant chunk
right but 5 G's getting rolled out
nationwide
that's the name of your last dump you
took giant chunk yeah Godzilla that
[ __ ] bathroom what's up fight nanny
he seemed quiet there's just so much
energy I don't need to even think it's
too much for you yeah do you believe in
this 5g buhbuh buhbuh never even heard
of it you guys teach me so much on the
show I've got a baby and I just got
nipples I just don't got the news
dude that's why you're great [ __ ] the
news yeah that's bad sounds bad do you
believe there's people still watching
Rachel Maddow it cracks me up
she lied to them for two years and
they're still watching it it's just like
we're a country of Stockholm Syndrome
we love our captors we love our [ __ ]
kidnappers we love they're like they're
that bad it's like people getting mad
when you [ __ ] say politicians are
liars and they literally know they're
lying they let her know they vote for
them knowing this is how I know why I
told respect my women go nuts
probably guys because we court you to
get the snatch and then we get it and
then we just ghost you like yeah and
that's why you go it's same thing with
[ __ ] politicians they literally tell
us everything they want we want to hear
and this is they get elected to like
[ __ ] you other clown [ __ ] anyways what's
up with the draft dude if you're a
kidnapper would you have sex with your
your captives no because then you do it
is just say 18 year old cheerleader
blonde hair big tits and you got her
like tied up to a chair
it sounds really specific already kidnap
wait why aren't you going your yapper
for money I am a kidnapper
you're the kidnapper or Kim Kardashian's
kidnapper no I'm not kidnapping somebody
I'm not gonna get raped did you have
kidnapping some idiot that doesn't need
some cracking creepiest you have a
friend that currently has someone
kidnapped you guys are like discussing
this look if I was kidding I'd be
insulted that they didn't want to have
sex
exactly right be like you don't think
I'm hot well that's because seems like a
deal that's because the story's not real
that's why Kim Kardashian's star [ __ ]
fell because she totally got busted
lying about that whole thing it was a
complete lie about getting robbery
that's why she got busted and a story
just died because and that's why they
almost got canceled cuz they got busted
faking a robbery
it's like talking about William
Montgomery this hasn't been proven Wow
by the way you got it you got it you
gotta say when it's not a hundred
percent you know I ought to say any of
that I'm I would say I'm right at a
ninety five percent clip all right for
sure this is not Tim well hat this is
punch-drunk sport can we say quick can I
say farewell to somebody real quick
goodbye Los Angeles Clippers great
season Glory's over great snow who knew
it
who knew it and even in your playoff run
we still had to hear but the Lakers that
weren't even in the playoff good way to
talk off mic I told everybody there
somebody give me a pin I can put on my
jacket oh I must say something's gonna
be very controversial Kevin Durant is
the clothes thing to Michael Jordan
we've had haven't you read his killer
instinct he wants to murder you high
plays angry about that that's my theory
that's not talk what do you guys think I
don't I'm not I don't I think that's a
stretch and I'm gonna can I say some I
want on the record right now the Lakers
say they have a GM who wants to join
their team but he's got a team in the
playoffs oh they can't announce it would
you like me to announce who I think it's
gonna be James Harden do it no he it's
gonna be Neil O'Shea the Portland
Trailblazers
GM who used to be a soap box soap opera
actor in Los Angeles I heard a warmer
clip
for [ __ ] GM who went to Portland to
go to a more stable guy then the owner
died so I guarantee you he's going to
come back to LA so you heard of here
Neal poche of the Portland Trailblazers
I also have a theory and I theorize that
it's John Singleton famous director who
died that right that's crazy
John hold on stop you literally said
that and worse not you dumb [ __ ] what
are you crazy yeah that's great acting
thank you thank you
guess what guys you want to bet on the
rest of the playoffs how would you do
that say I would go to bat TS I bet the
acai for all your Betty needs go to
Betty sigh use the promo code punch 25
punch 25 you'll get $25 betting cash and
you don't even have to bet on sports
guys you can bet on TV shows and a lot
of stuff American Idol you can bet on
American Idol do you do both you decide
- of course I do why would I do anything
else but Betty aside and I use infinite
CBD now here's the thing about Betty
aside okay here's the thing love to hear
it if you want to make a bet and if you
win get your money out do not enroll
into the bonus don't road into the bonus
because if you enroll in the bonus okay
you get a date you have to bet so much
get your money I takes you awhile to get
your money okay no it's just your bike
you can win more you can right yeah but
don't if you have just roll in and and
just make a quick roll and roll you want
to make a quick bet mmm
they'll double anything you put in up to
500 bucks so if you put in 500 bucks
guess what you have it now a thousand
and twenty five dollars to bet if you
want to enroll in the bone if you want
to roll so I'll make that straight cash
homie just going bet just bet in get out
get out get in get in and out I also
want to give a shout-out to our good
friends at absolute axe no let's finish
the [ __ ] promo we're gonna be GS I
bet the acai you're gonna be able to get
bad sports but I'm trying to get them to
do conspiracy theories well that's hard
to do no it's not
yeah it is no you do okay okay okay it's
like who shot JFK why Jeff God you win
$100 into one Jeff
I'm betting are just flat it was Betty
aside that's why I don't understand how
like I really want to know how they do
the TV shows that Betty si because you
know I know somebody that just got back
from a certain TV show overseas on an
island survivor and like they already
know who won an area think so does that
mean I got the Stuart insider info I'm
sure the money is so low like four bucks
you probably get back 20 bucks to win
fifties they're not gonna cry over
[ __ ] know people just hit me up on the
last fight night with Jacare somebody
did a for all five fights got all five
of them right use our code anyone like
450 bucks for my good friends at bet TS
I know hit me up gave the banker a I'm a
but up down a bit basically even with my
dog he is doing a benefit he said for
Robert Schimmel daughter is what
happened to his daughter I know she's he
says I don't know he can you help him do
to benefit for Robert Schimmel his for
his daughter I don't even know I'm
bringing all the chickies row get
married to the other is Rogen's know
that is a that is a conspiracy that you
should say is true I heard Rogan
Ryan Karen is his brother because one
one day Joe says my brother from another
mother
and then I like on IMDB and everything
that says Brian Cowen brother of Joe
Rogan shoot me so yeah go to bet this I
make bets on who Brogan's married to and
dating who his family is ongoing
ancestry.com and find out soon as well
find out - so that's bet Dias I thank
you guys um what you asked question
about me yeah I was gonna see if
anybody's been to 23andme so horny right
now if any of your family [ __ ] Asian
hookers yeah yeah yeah I just have a
great bit about how any time you put
Asian hookers in a movie it's a better
movie has there been one movie
Asian hookers that wasn't a great movie
I can't think of a movie with Full Metal
Jacket jacket of course it's a name one
movie world oh wait Wayne's World
I'm in third chicken name a movie that
saw Star Wars Star Wars Majan it with
Asian hookers how much better is better
Schindler's List imagine it with Asian
hookers right it would be fatter I
adelphia
I um Hanks you have AIDS now me love you
know long time I Edition for as
Schindler's fist oh man
went straight to producers but didn't
get it who's your favorite your award
show Charlotte Stokely oh she's great
she's so watching I've seen her get
powned by black guys a lot of them at
once that hard before not everybody ah
but she she's actually this elbow deep
in her yes like crazy I didn't even need
Lube ya know she was such a sweetheart
I love Bailey rain I think she's the
heart oh yeah she was so nice Johnny was
here to show me all these um I'm jerking
off the old porn like most chicks I beat
off like that horn are dead eighties
born yeah I just dropped it I cut out
the middleman I just took off two dead
chicks I go to go to dead calm she gives
me some [ __ ] smoke show I only beat
off to Nina Hartley's latest videos
watch breaking Amish she is I think
they're popular to know they told how
old is she
and tell her she's like she's like I
think 60 but in porn years a thousand
years old oh yeah her [ __ ] looks like
his face yeah yeah I had her on a
podcast once and she did you really
scarf at my studio like a scarf that's
our merch
Tom rags is our merchant dude I was
gonna do that with [ __ ] porn stars
and ivory but either jerk-off max I
remembered I remember that well it was
anything crazy like that happened when
you were there like you walked into the
green room and you're like holy [ __ ] you
know we're shooting like these videos
and the director was like everybody take
your clothes off except for you pointing
to me and
and so like if that was like the
craziest thing like everybody was so
professional and I was like you guys
have to you don't have to be so
professional around me right right you
know II mean I don't I'm gonna meet to
anybody here it came out right feel free
it's coming out Saturday yeah have you
got to see it yet no I haven't seen it
windy and you shot it with January oh
wow yeah they add a lot of other like
tips at us you know in the editing
process so but yeah I love it I mean
it's fun dude
it's fun it's funny because these girls
naughty show she don't take themselves
seriously you know like they're like
crying over who won oh I'm bringing it
back though I'm bringing her now to show
back where we're doing it downtown
there's this promoter that wants
downtown yeah we're bringing it back new
naughty [ __ ] awesome did you see the I
know we haven't talked about it yet but
the Dare until losses [ __ ] yeah did you
hear about that oh yeah yeah that's
[ __ ] like so explicit it's gonna look
it up or not but actually you say cuz
you know more of the details yeah Canary
Islands and we got wasted and trashed
his hotel room and then somebody else
for buddies so a lot of guys with the
fire extinguisher
yeah they destroyed a hotel room with
the fire extinguishers UFC fighter
standard the standard party maybe they
were just on blue - good it looks nobody
gonna want to try but and then so they
get kicked out of that hotel didn't they
try to go to another hotel from what I
understand and they're too drunk and Ike
the person hotels like it's for like
just hammered you have C fine it's
almost like [ __ ] Jason mayhem Miller
kind of a situation and just the guide
the hotels like just looked at him and
it's like yeah this next the craziest so
then they get a cab the cab shows up and
while the cab drivers like loading their
luggage into the trunk or something yeah
they just steal the cab
yeah and they drive amazing I just feel
the cab he seems very normal - so that's
why it's so shock yeah he's not like a
mayhem Miller type but apparently he
[ __ ] is
yeah apparently he is yeah cuz you know
Sam's not even impressed by the stories
like I do this every weekend yeah I've
done that before what happens to you
your record like when you steal a cab
well I mean like I mean I wasn't me I
was in a high-speed car chase for the
cops did you steal the cab no but they
were chased that true yeah yeah that's
all I remember this
it was long to you on Travis remember
they were chasing you cop helicopters
were out there trying to find me dude
it's a joke I did my special girls I
barely parked my car that's how I do but
why were they chasing you though
because I kept my car and this tow truck
had parked illegally and I hit it and I
was like where's the guy come fine so I
scoped out my mind so I [ __ ] and he
started in your car alone me and Scott
Ross okay yeah yeah and we were driving
he's just gonna fall asleep laughing
right he's narcoleptic he would answer
the door like to get rent because he was
like our landlord at the time or
whatever manager yeah and he would be
like hey I'm here to get to catch me
catch me literally would say catch me
while he would fall asleep standing at
my front door collecting eradicated no
cuz he goes to your shows every week I
don't know yeah yeah he's medicube
oh I have a lot I have a lot so he's not
enough left and riding in your car and
you're running from the cops coked up
yeah I know and we're chasing us all
through Hollywood all through West
Hollywood we're not stopping for I'm not
stopping for [ __ ] stop signs or
anything always a smart we're straight
up remember the movie Ronan where
they're just doing those quicks [ __ ]
yeah yeah yeah so we're running through
it we get in front of this um this this
gay bar and he goes up on the sidewalk
et back he tees the whole thing trying
to stop traffic I'm like I'm dry
remember my old uh Mustang that you got
from much as face hablo Francisco I'm
like oh [ __ ] it I back it up dude that's
a long time ago and I [ __ ]
jumped the median boom I well where I'm
Sam you know in the middle on cinema oh
yeah yeah yeah jump it boom Wow yeah and
I [ __ ] take off and dude I call that
one go this guy's trying to [ __ ] kill me
goes wait a police helicopters and cops
looking for you right now I'm like [ __ ]
you I'm gon hang up and I hello and I
Valle parked my car my body comes into a
light at the standard uh-huh the [ __ ]
where you used to work yeah yeah this is
the [ __ ] mas comes picks me up I jump
in a [ __ ] car I called the cops and I
go hey man you guys are like chasing me
[ __ ] around he goes yeah where are you
I go dude I'm gone I'm not even in LA
anymore I go this [ __ ] was
trying to kill me my friend and I never
heard from them again
so one day like two weeks later I'm
driving my car
these [ __ ] Russians these Albanian
dudes pull up inside me go pull your car
over and they [ __ ] make me pull over
same car no this was a different car
okay I go what's up he goes hey dawg you
[ __ ] hit my tow truck and you [ __ ]
ran go yeah and I have [ __ ] witnesses
in the car saying you're trying to run
me off the [ __ ] Road and trying to
[ __ ] hurt us and anytime you want to
do this let's call the [ __ ] cops and
I never heard from them again and that
was the end of it that's crazy oh and
you know what made that story better
Asian hookers yeah yeah
Russian hookers with Aaron today he
loves his podcast so much more my other
one aired he never loved all that
baseball talk earlier yeah that's inside
baseball games you know what if I did I
would go into an Arizona Cardinals game
because I think they're going to make
the playoffs
well that's football why do you think
they're gonna make the playoffs ten
there one please favorite team at
Aaron's least favorite team did you
watch the fights no did you watch them
Sam where are you watching Josh Martin
had it
in the back of the back maybe I should
just go there yeah because hello is just
having on the back TV I just said it was
literally just me and Josh Martin
watching he's like this is the dumbest
fight I've ever seen
sounds fun so like I really missed out
soccer a terrible I did it so miserable
but that's like that was him being happy
Oh David D redoing as a producer it's
great I yeah not Josh actually it was an
amazing producer at kill Tony he knew a
shitty very detail-oriented
I bought walkie-talkies yesterday though
so we should have him next week so that
we all have walked you know he just did
it for four years or three years or
something and it's not doing anything I
need to move on with my life but now
Dave's great he you know it's hard
there's a lot to learn for that job sure
a lot of moving parts right yeah it's
actually yeah and like last night was
sold out
so we have to like filter through all
the comics put the comics in a special
place and the VIP people and it's but
you know it's just like it's like
running a show on top of putting
together like electronics and cameras
and you know sure you know how it is
I don't yeah you don't you're doing it
tonight two shows you're yeah it's like
two shows a stress that yeah yeah it's
like it's like [ __ ] managing all
these monsters and you're all killers
they're all cell theaters they're all
[ __ ] and you just got to make sure
everybody's happy they're all wonderful
people but you got to make sure
everybody's happy no one's mad where
they're going or Falls from the last
comedy chaos
Tiffany Haddish is still on stage right
now
[Laughter]
uh you should just you know the big
thing is just watch watching getting
that green room man last night I wonder
if your Creator it was like there's like
a hundred people in there it's like now
there's like nobody in there and
exploring you know but like a lot of
comments and love that they need like
some quiet time yeah you know to get
back coaches in the NFL and in college
football it's like a guy who constantly
keeps telling people to get off the
field and that's their job is just go up
and down like get back your back of it
because it's a penalty if a bunch of
people on the field so if you think it
breaks out so you just need somebody
that's constantly every hour goes 45
minutes like a get out get out get out
get up not help for you I mean like when
you're doing these shows know Dana who's
drunk running around [ __ ] she's helps
a lot yeah I was gonna say I feel like
you and Dana like kick people out more
than every 45 minutes I try to do it
just seasoned huh in between the shows
I'll let it be packed and so all these
guys you know you know shows up and that
really is place to chill if you're about
to go on or just got off that's what
abstract is nice and off their big part
of the show great to have a great
product donuts to go to a BX org and
check them out okay man coffees great to
make coffee he's a code punch-drunk
right yeah go to pun I think it's 10%
15% off that [ __ ] and if please do it
because tape made it very specific if
you guys don't start selling some
caveman coffee I'm going to rip Tebow in
half like a phone book and [ __ ] both
sides of it I want to read you some of
the awesome comments from love conquers
all ha ha ha ha ha
I'm sure that means we're all gonna die
and so focus so these have like tons of
[ __ ] lights my ahkahuna
kid ha a Hanukkah or what is an angry
face that's real fun I could knock ah ha
ha ha ha ah so
good comments
hey guys on my YouTube I am literally
240 subscribers away from my goal of 50k
if you guys can go and hit hit that
subscribe help me out that'd be great
that was my goal when I started you know
Donnell I like to do more but right now
I really want to do you know I also
would like to if everybody could please
follow me on MySpace I have 11 friends
and I'm trying to get to 20 they just
lose everybody's music somebody just
said I swear to God in my email I got a
thing that's like so-and-so just hit you
up on my face I'm like is that a thing
yeah I've been on myspace in 10 years go
to my space.com slash red band and see
if it's still there I heard that they
just like had all these files corrupted
in all these bands like millions of
money off of it that's the only thing
myspace was doing was making doing me
timber later somebody here just remember
late is it it's my top eight store maybe
that's it and then they turned to a top
would you take them out of it I did no
TiVo is in my top and I think you were
to you were definitely my sure I think
you were my top to my top I didn't know
you did in the myspace yeah I didn't
know yeah that's when your black eye
face but you were in my top it was
almost twenty I was like nineteen but a
few money oh my god I got me too I love
it only re beat us he was like 27 23
what he's like 23 24 yeah every time Oh
mozi college I was in his real
yeah but once the girl saw his balls
they just rang he got raped by the
Maryland stop cuz now it's like he's
always using those he got raped by the
Maryland women's basketball team guys
subscribe to our patreon page don't
forget we got an intern up this week has
anyone heard from mark I know he's
moving into his new place he was giving
you away oh it's a long process
oh yeah my girlfriend's lay what do you
guys have on your patreon oh yeah what
kind of stuff but we have a what do you
get would it get yeah you get I do a
special show at The Comedy Store called
conspiracies now where I just get people
to come talk about the weirdest [ __ ] and
then I also call telemarketers or tech
support and when they tell me the phone
is the call is being recorded I ask them
are we recording this they go yeah we're
a go you cool that there you go yeah
and then I talk I'm recording - well I
don't tell them that no no and then I
record because they're Filipino you have
the Filipino customer service people all
sound like one personal Oh mom real
quick for $800 Dan what date did I say
do tell tell marketing so I read to that
I read April hold on it's a 100 straight
yeah it's phone for the 1930s as well
okay the worksheet mystified is
government servitude for a franchise
just because they're all so big No yeah
hundred dollars make a holler right okay
man that's good
so this is on the record I'd like to say
something I'd like to say that George
Bush Senior was in Dallas the day the
JFK got shot he was there and he was
part of it he's most likely wore one of
the three hobos that were there but he
was definitely there and when Trump
released all CIA documents it literally
said that George Bush was in Dallas on
that day
and yet we all know George Bush is a
lizard person he was part of you know
he's basically part of the CIA the
record I get conspiracies on the wreck
[Laughter]
amazing you hear that all my Patriot and
then we do a patriot at the copy store
every every week I've done that a couple
times yes you have sports band man he's
our friend sports band getting really
crazy you know Esther has vaginal
scoliosis
we're having a sideways vagina talk
about is it weird having your
gynecologist just breaking news we have
doctor-patient confidentiality why not
Esther she's a beautiful Asian woman
everyone thinks I'm a dad dating Esther
she's like on the record like you just
did it like a couple weeks ago video we
are not the same person well no one's
ever seen us and the same room together
that should be the same time Janice just
like just like dombarris and jimmy
kimmel you know Tom Berry's this Jimmy
Kimmel without makeup on conspiracies I
like dude if you see what's been
happening with Britney Spears oh my god
controls for her life somebody tell me
oh I'm so excited head like she doesn't
have any control her life like people
make decisions for her like what she
wears we got so Asian right there make
decision for ha what do you mean like
she just wakes up without a permission
for her that actually made me hard
thanks blue chill come on kids so yeah
they medicate her like she's on a
schedule her dad like fully as like a
staff that takes now you know that I'm
in a Britney Spears video hey what yeah
I mean isn't she doesn't you have a
residency in Vegas no here let me tell
you sorry so not anymore
Walter this is part of the story so
basically we're
finds out this guy Sam lefty or whatever
his name is supposedly allegedly was
drugging her so her dad had to come in
kick him the [ __ ] out and he became
conservator of all things Brittany right
so the first video she does her father
her father okay the first video she does
is with Wayne Isham Dana Marshall and
it's called piece of me and it's based
off of video that Jason I did call fake
heat where I got fake paparazzi to
follow me around all that [ __ ]
well they do the video you can see her
stepping over me which is what she
really did I got to see where babies
come from and that video puts it back on
track it's first time she wins cause of
you raise your cameo base bumped up her
number so anyways that was almost like I
think eight years ago I was I don't even
know how long ago I was only 2007
something like that right so it's 11
years ago something like that so he's
been in charge of her forever
so at some point she wants to get off
her medication she doesn't want to take
the medication anymore he's like you're
staying on that [ __ ] reason to cut us
meds yeah this was after so her
residency bouncing but this is why like
she said I can't do it so there's this
podcast called Britney Graham and they
they do a podcast she on it or is it her
fans are on can I tell the story no a
goddamn question is it podcast holy
thank you it's these two comedians right
and they do a job Barbara gray I think
she's one of them yes they went on enews
they were like protesting what who is
Pro oh yeah I blew up it blew up okay no
standing up for Britney so they have
this this this phone number you can call
and anything Britney you can call and
talk
well this paralegal calls from this law
firm ace no longer and he's like oh I
can't tell you my name I worked at this
legal firm to handle Britney's
conservatory she has been forced into a
mental facility for since January
against her will because her father
won't let her get off her drugs she
doesn't want to take the medication
anymore and he's making her
he's making her be in a conservatory
making her be in a mental facility now
she wanted to get off her meds and her
dad's like no if you get off your meds
I'm canceling because she's about to do
a new show I'm canceling your new show
heõs I want off my meds he cancels the
show she sold out every show she ever
did The Palms was sold out I mean at the
Planet Hollywood was sold out he threw
her in Atkins in a [ __ ] mental
facility forcing her to take meds and it
wasn't because because of this podcast
basically blew up this whole story she
was now released have you seen her she's
like a cuckoo tell me that well story
once again I've kind of wasn't paying
attention she's not off the meds still
right or is she off the meds now she
looks like she looks like she's off
she looks like a different person Johnny
pull that up probably got Chloe
something here someone went up to Dave
Chappelle and asked him if he was a
clone he goes how would I know if I'm a
clone enough how would I know
Wow it's all for money right because he
controls her finances so he doesn't want
her to take control of her own fine I
mean honestly she makes horrible life
decisions I think she's not mentally
well and does need to be you [ __ ] a
backup dancer like do you need to be
punished for the rest of your life for
getting him Paul no because she she gets
she gets drugged she was gotten drugged
by that guy that's why she's going
[ __ ] nuts he's drugging her all the
time
kind of like Anna Nicole Smith and that
Howard case Stern guy that Sam guy was a
piece of [ __ ] they're all pieces of [ __ ]
they got it there next just because
you're related to them doesn't mean you
need to like keep in touch with them
dude and all those all those Mickey
Mouse Club kids are all [ __ ] in the
head and some of them just handle it
better and just you know it's like
Justin Timberlake Christina Aguilera a
Miley Cyrus like [ __ ] easy thing I see
Miley Cyrus is a five-tool player she's
so super talented she just grew up in
front of them on Instagram and
everything and she's lettin people
finger blaster at her [ __ ]
people just like where other concerts
you know no jerk-off to those videos
where send me email email me the link oh
okay so now we just got told that we
have to end this show even though we
have three [ __ ] minute he knows it
takes three minutes for you to calm down
if there's one thing we've learned about
Britney Spears is that families are just
for people that can't make a lot of
friends
[ __ ] families you know what I gotta say
fred durst got so much [ __ ] for banging
Britney Spears back in the day that was
what went limp Biskit just went to [ __ ]
it was like you [ __ ] sell off your
baby pretty seriously at that time
everybody would have banged Britney
Spears it's still bang her today oh
absolutely
watch you guys [ __ ] still make her
scream if you don't want Olympus bleu
cheese yeah I could hundred why you got
technique 98% of the girls I have we're
gonna show I'm [ __ ] that propaganda
that's [ __ ] propaganda from this hey
Bama squirt okay this has been the
squirting podcast ladies if you squirt
you wanna come on talk about it hit us
up Thank You Esther ku where one more
time where they can find you on the
Internet at Esther ku calm at Esther ku
ku and Instagram and Twitter Haitian
stop player hating on the Asians okay
we're tired this asian on asian crime
read ban anything you want pretty
promote Friday you haven't see a lot of
surprises maybe Sam will be there may be
cheap who knows maybe ice house I stop
30 come to the ice out Thank You Betty
asides Thank You blue chew Oh this
Saturday I'm Pro Wrestling I'm Pro
Wrestling Alice mania I'm Armageddon
that's my character and I'm do my first
pro wrestling bout suck it